[Music]
all right start started starting it
starting it up yeah
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to another episode hands around
the [ __ ] so yells Hannibal Buress and
I'm talking way different cuz I'm I'm hi
I heard I sound like one of those
[ __ ] they'll be on v-103 mm-hmm
the late night oh you listening to the
RB what was that [ __ ] called OGC on
Babylon quiet storm you listenin citta
to quiet storm Tony is enamored with his
new drone kids the pedals I love these
fan titles
[Music]
hi my name is Tony trim and I am your
co-host of the handsome Rambler and just
all-around nice guy
oh yeah our guest good friend second
time on the shelves right second timer
in this [ __ ]
over my ego all goodbye geek oh good
good evening what's up man nothing
putting drums them drums is up
how's your levels everybody's good yeah
well good man yeah feel welcome how's it
going yeah it's going good last time we
did a podcast this late last time we've
recorded episode this late we didn't put
that episode out that's not the one I
heard is it yeah yeah that was the best
one ever
amazing
that's the Danny Brown episode that's
the future award-winning episode of
handsome Rambler change lives yeah I get
the most requests for that one yeah man
because they we've told them about it
they hear they hear about it so didn't
they it was mythical now you've got a
lore attached to it but I've heard it
and I'm going to tell you now the
[ __ ] episode is a maze oh it's tough
what is judo know I hear you know I know
cuz there's a good there's a good two
thirds over the people should never hear
yeah but it's still amazing like it's
amazing it's an amazing occurrence even
if some of it oh um you know you know
what I felt like listening to that I
felt like man it's two of my home he's
drunk in the green room having a real
life fat conversation yeah but it's not
for the world to hear not most not most
of I think you know about about 45% of
it can go out to the world right 55
y'all got it y'all got keep that yes you
know I say we I say we just probably
gotta just do another one I know I know
I mean this is some gold in there but I
feel cuz it you know he'll be stitching
it up would be quite good Oh Jeff maybe
we can play with it structurally where
we have the parts of that are very
incomprehensible just wild talk and then
kind of commentate on it in sober time
like a director's director's cut of a
podcast that's that's where every listen
this is where I was here see this is
good now we're getting deep I'm telling
you you're gonna win in a war based off
that episode look at where it's pushing
you you're gonna you're gonna change the
form yeah cuz I really just I just
just how many ways to fix it and make it
better than it is and that the crazy
talk you that is now you know the crazy
talk is part of life crazy happens on
your podcast anyway right that's part of
it it gets that too much crazy talk cuz
you know it's good I don't we don't do
them that often we do a few at a time
and get a head up I get him so I don't
that's one thing I always I worried
about going in was doing them often and
then feeling the need to just share
everything right with you got some [ __ ]
you got to go twice a week or three like
I listen even radio people where you
just when they just have to talk about
whatever just happening whatever
whatever is happening even [ __ ] about it
they gotta [ __ ] and so yeah that's
why I'm like we do them and we might not
do something for a month and a half of
them but you I mean but it come out
pretty regularly alright yeah we block
yeah we just do a silent yeah this is
interesting stuff people just talk about
[ __ ] yes father's got absent bring we
bring expensive cars to your house is
that is that what happened sir oh my god
sir oh man can you be broken news Toro
its of just a rental car thing right but
like what if you really don't have that
much money but you want to rent a
Ferrari in LA what did woody what is
just to row no did you ain't got that
much money it I mean it's a Ferrari cars
you know I mean you should probably
based on your life you put in the price
filters down I see okay yeah but I mean
what if this what if you you know you
just got a thousand dollars of spare you
was like [ __ ] on one day I want to
test the roast over two three days like
you can do that if you give you have it
on your account new owns and they're
just gonna bring it to me and I look
dirty and it's gonna leave it with me
because I ordered it and it's already
paid for
yeah this is shirt this is great
that was a great alternate ad vitur oh
man I woke up looking dirty and I
already paid for it they're gonna honor
that [ __ ] like no matter what I'll be
trying summer in a helicopter some [ __ ]
man I want to make it happen
people do have Ferraris on there but
they be like going for 900 days 700 days
okay you're right yeah that's
prohibitive I wouldn't do that if I
didn't have a lot of money because
that's too much money for one day for
anything no no yeah it's pretty crazy
that's not stupid and difficult to just
rent the Ferrari from any place though
right you can't just go get a Ferrari
from enterprise you know el lado they
got a bunch of them luxury motor rental
places yeah it's just a luxury luxury
spy's not Havis so something might have
some business a Jaguar vette but when
you talk about Ferraris s Kobe yeah a
special spot but I don't want to I don't
even want to drive down like that anyway
I'm too nervous
it's yeah you look like an [ __ ] yes
true I had that I had the Alfa Romeo I
drove a red eye for a rail for two days
and already won yeah all the way there
it was it was a brain I kind of impulse
got it on an app like oh that's a flat
car would be Hawking and I got what am i
is it like a two-seater it's a
two-seater it's like that type of car
yeah and it's tough to drive it's not an
easy drive it's just there's a type of
card as is cool to have no power
steering if you just hours do no per
house did
yeah uh that's shitty with Tony look
like when I went there in that invisible
car right now great it's a workout just
to drive that goddamn car yeah it was it
just felt I felt like a douche bag with
that car it's the only time I've been
driving in Chicago and I was at a
stoplight and somebody ran up to the car
it was like can I take a picture with
you that's weird I Drive in Chicago out
of time right but he was cuz of the car
it was like what the [ __ ] is do with
that car oh [ __ ]
what are you usually driving Chicago I
get a convertible yellow comparable like
I used to get some type of sedan I got
either the Lincoln or a bears but some
[ __ ] that's black something accessible
yeah black and just low key that sounds
marvelous
the Audi you can't go wrong with Audi
even the lowest model Audi just so
beautiful
their greatness their great colors for
automobile very proud of Chicago took my
car why did the city take your car cuz I
old have a lot of money for parking
tickets and were you just not paying him
off a principal or something the
principle of being broke okay this was
olden days yeah this is 2005 January
2005 it took your whole car it took my
whole car leave that [ __ ] was so
scarring that I kind of I was for my
comedy career then it was before my car
was taken and then after that it was
such a mark of wit cuz when I was able
able to get two gigs easier do some like
quick out-of-town [ __ ] maybe you'll just
even go to the south side easy it took
my car that [ __ ] changed everyday to
move from Chicago 2008 okay I thought
maybe they move cuz they took your car
he's a [ __ ] hunters live anywhere now
that might have been part of it I mean I
wouldn't have made that crazy move in
2006 if if I had a car
cago I just when I just I probably would
have got a car like a blessing in
disguise of what it sounds like maybe
man silver lining
maybe no one does it goes hey you know
we just I'm kind of in a weird mood
because I watch watch cut loose man you
you do you do the car broken I'm sorry
Cubs lost Cubs lost from a [ __ ] home
run a walk-off walk-off yeah yeah I'm
not happy about that bro but it's also
you know so big so big so big the Cubs
lost Soviet left the Dodger Stadium
that [ __ ] was terrible took about an
hour walk for miles got a bunch of steps
on my Fitbit but I didn't plan for that
[ __ ] took an hour walking through a
forest preserve all types of terrain
sand concrete grass walk past the cops
pop pop rock in front of a cop doing
doughnuts while I eat doughnuts that's
my go-to line smoking a joint drinking
vodka orange juice is fine Oh Tony
fingers on the drums
that's the heartbroken song really have
no wallet started that way and Tony was
the solo because he was doing the drum
so I feel like no matter what you say
ultimately it was gonna be heartbroken
cuz it's rooted in was rooted in pain
slow it down want that go like this you
[Music]
[ __ ] no chillin on the show my Eagle on
again my Eagle you all taught how to
[ __ ] his bed it's actually been great I
was gonna try to rap but I was doing a
little organelle thing it's tough now
welcome the same time I wasn't even
gonna I just bailed on it yeah and I
didn't even rap I just decided you just
got a hold on locator you got a little
rhythm going so I was you know it was
really it was it was demanding of my
body you know it was I got you yeah I'm
sorry I'm not good at this yet okay I've
seen you on stage before obviously
that's that's me playing with [ __ ] that
I'm used to you know you wouldn't let me
bring all my stuff
Tony so now I got to play with your
stuff and now I was a learning curve you
know this is the this is the handsome
Rambla world you have to work you have
to work with the handsome Rambler well
then you'll set a hands your Ramblers
got to be goddamn patient with me
[Music]
no it's good it's actually been going
super dope though cause I've been like
selling out shows and [ __ ] and I never
did that before so like it's been really
amazing and I'm really like having one
of them I'm like trying to actually slow
down and soak it all in
yeah it was like I'm playing up really
like you was in New York right I was
told this story on stage that I played
that room the first time and it was
eight people in there and then you know
to go back now and it sold out but it's
a lot of the same wounds that I'm in on
this tour and it was shitty
so like this [ __ ] is cold damn yeah
that's what my [ __ ] progress god damn
it do you think is a combination of
going to those cities a bunch plus the
new album or just plus just grinded with
I think it's awesome Paris's I think
it's grinding I think it's appearances I
think my the way my whole career works
is just a bunch of different drops in
the bucket you know what I mean and you
know [ __ ] eventually the [ __ ] Rises
and you know starts to tip one way or
another that kind of thing so you know I
people come to my shows they might have
heard me on doing my Adventure Time
podcasts and heard me on Marin or whips
or some [ __ ] you know what I mean it's
not like everybody's been along for the
whole ride right people access to [ __ ] a
bunch of different ways then they
apologize to I don't know it's like it's
fine just go go go get it
yeah I attract a lot of uncomfortable
people to myself a lot of a lot of
people just don't know what to do
because they do when they're outside
what what do you guys talk about in the
Adventure Time podcast we used to be
used to break down episodes we used to
do like top five character lists we used
to discuss you know storylines and all
type of [ __ ] man we saw so van like a
fam podcast it was but we interviewed
the voice actors the creators the
writers storyboard artists all of that
[ __ ] but debate the basis of it was me
and his dude John Moe just you know
coming up with different theories and
thoughts and [ __ ] about the show holy
[ __ ] yes I've heard adventure time is
super dope and layered but it's not even
like
you can own it you know I did yeah yeah
I've watched the episode of but I think
deep in but but the thing is - if you
just watched a random episode it could
be like a self-contained kind of almost
throwaway episode yeah or it could be
part of the overall big story you know
what I mean it's kind of hard just to
you know watch man I think they just did
they did they on the tenth season now I
think I want to say it's a ten
that's another thing that just happened
because I was just on there - and that
happened like two days after my album
came out so like that was you know a big
deal in my world and [ __ ] - yeah but
yeah this is the last season you watch
this [ __ ] Tony what's against I watched
a few episodes high and I remember me
like yo it's just oh yes deep man I
guess do yeah it's weird as hell we're
gonna get and it gets weirder - like the
longer you watch it yeah it's like acid
trippy here it's our kids 90 30 minutes
a day 15 you know like you know 15 with
commercials so okay twelve can knock out
a few of those on a flight did so you're
gonna give a bunch of them if you want
to fly it in I never seen it on a fly
never seen it offered on the flight I'm
talking about
they cuz I own Netflix right now no I
think Hulu but yeah yeah marketed for
kids right it's a kid show marketed for
kids yet but it's definitely got a
layered appeal it appeals to adults of
[ __ ] oh just cause they do wild [ __ ]
okay wild did you do did you do the
voice acted in your voice did you put on
a voice nah cuz I was rapping so I had
to do my voice I wouldn't do like what
was the rapping character
I was gingerbread man and then I was
also these three squirrels but they all
have my voice they all had the same
voice you think they pitched the
background ones up but they was all me
no one lead me yeah having background
Me's that was pitched up that is crazy
yeah yeah I've done some animation I've
done they do and they'll do some filters
or change the pitch a little bit in our
watch the cartoon I don't sound like
that
haha sound yeah that could be offensive
what the [ __ ] I just heard you in on
what the [ __ ] was out watching it random
we saw you in the nice guys as the beat
yeah that [ __ ] was weird as hell I'm
watching the movie half sleep on the
airplane and all of a sudden
Hannibal ass is a B and in a talking B
in the middle of a movie that was mostly
real how did you even get that role from
what I heard I think the producer saw me
on a Bieber roast and then wanted me off
for that I guess if if that's what the
story is that movie was funny as [ __ ]
don't go well shot that actress the girl
they played the daughter she was real
good she was everything wait was she she
was in spider-man Action Alliance see
spider-man see but I met her on on set
is where when you meet a kid and you
like oh kid use weird fanning out on a
kid
hey good [ __ ] on that [ __ ] right it's
one of the kids from blackish
yo what up kid actor scare me man like
like one is it like they're really good
like my sixth sense member haylie job
yeah he was really good he lose crazy
[ __ ] now you seen yeah yeah he's on uh
he was on the last season of what
Silicon Valley yeah looking like an old
ass baby [ __ ] minute she's on random
[ __ ] yeah I see him pop up but uh yeah
he I think when they get those young
actors they look younger than they
actually are actually older but they
look young like Webster oh yeah I think
Webster was old when he was like a grown
man yeah yeah what's that I don't know
what that disease is where like you just
don't grow up but you look young forever
I don't know what the Gary Coleman had
it to this is how sue sees a disease
Juicy J well he will have a disease
named after him one day he's
he just looks like but he doesn't say
that doesn't really like he aged he came
out the womb look at 38 I'm sure says
held strong Juicy J up it [ __ ] you know
it is I'm with the click to say I'm
smoking blunts I'm out here don't give
it [ __ ] no of North Memphis you know
that isn't to say partying all day X say
Papa Juicy J that's always called Juicy
J oh you know you pump it up okay what
up yeah Pamela oven is it we Epona [ __ ]
I got that paramount may Terrebonne
runway Babylon weather was going on now
I sing the song sounding praises but on
a beat Tony trim on the drums get the
liquor store vino on the drums trigger
no Pinot Grigio
my shoes got repo'd I really wish I only
had three toes cuz then I get a discount
all pedicures is that a deal in desert
it sure is except for people in the
pedicure big walk-in maybe like hose
this huh I'm just because he got toes
missing what the [ __ ] it's not worth my
time
yeah it ain't worth your time it ain't
worth your mind I got three toes I used
to have nine plus one three toes it's
way more fun
you only got thirty percent of the work
to be done used to chill only three toes
you gotta feel I know that these gross
but you could do it for muscle memory
and yeah yeah do you make the soaps on
the TV we fix my feet we can watch soap
but your feet is not dope and you should
know that you need more hope three oh
did you make it sound simple but no
because I work in front of the window
and I'm gonna scare all the local
kinfolks
when they see that you have less than
ten toes I have less than ten toes but
everybody know I got that [ __ ] on my
tender Pro faux profile make the word
than the profiles that was the problem
this show sponsored by tinder profiles
that was you know I really it really
took liberties with that that that old
rapper trick
well you mispronounced alert to fit
you're wrong oh like right now or yeah
okay send up rofo I mean profile that's
a gift to yourself you've got to take
that forward you can't just leave that
dick well this shit's going out in front
of the [ __ ] world yeah I gotta know
that you know what words are ten deploy
Chloe
I deleted my tender grab my bumble I'm
trying to grow up or you just walked out
on a bunch of weed Hey
same thing then AB mutually exclusive is
there a story here you can wrong that's
a guy I took too strongly pills smoke
and then any way God intended
no I wigged out in general but delete
might enjoy it was part of that high it
was part of the high left you trying to
go off the grid dick first did that make
sense to me took too many doses and just
[ __ ] went off to deeper Jess was
pacing alright this is less let's see I
was so high and pacing around so much it
was a good thing that I had a suite if I
I had to do that amount of pacing in a
normal room it would have been and like
I had a good amount of what what city
were you in Las Vegas
okay okay I guess yeah you don't really
want that's even worse you can't just go
for a walk outside and Las Vegas and
walk no I cannot just go nuts they want
no they're not worse you have to go out
yeah if I could take a lift out it's a
let me get myself together well useless
what is that there's some job like those
Japanese rice cracker Oh awesome
so many different kinds in there I like
variety different kinds of snacks yeah I
like it like seaweed paper
that's how I do it that's how I data
data I say hey girl wanna eat some rice
snacks and she's like yeah boy I like it
like ya gotta stop it peace to bend they
crunched that's how I do it when I
highlight girls with munchies yeah my
freestyle is about on point it's cuz the
Cubs lost and I need to smoke another
joint
that was terrible Oh Hannibal saving it
locally just sound like it's a
heartbreak just shooting in a gym man we
just shooting in the gym we just shoot
shots have a fun shooting shots having
fun shooting the shots having fun
shooting the sides having fun shooting
shots I'm stupid hot I can do a lot I'm
proving - [ __ ] I'll significant that
hi I'm old school I'll be watching
Matlock garbage and glad luck I'm half
smock other half is a pants suits I
harass you I am you yeah I can get all
up in your brain calls in pain I say
that cuz I am not ashamed on the name I
grabbed him like I know it's full of
flame that's the game I'm playing in
[ __ ] yo delaying what you sang it you
better sit there and you start bringing
the Sun there are something here I put
you in a dungeon and have you to eat
nothing you'll be starving I have a
haircut like James Harden no that's not
really true grab the microphone you'd be
like that's not really you I will watch
Hill Street groups and say that
should've been me back in the 80s get on
to order yourself a Mercedes for you and
your lady coz you've been driving a
bucket lately and she [ __ ] hates it
she said that on Facebook engaged you're
great look on Facebook she was on
Facebook I took the same religious Bible
study classes that may stood but it
didn't take give me a religion break
yo drink a raspberry of pigeon shake yo
you put a pigeon in a blender pigeon
shake that some [ __ ] they eat on Prison
Break next to some chicken steak yeah
hit it wait and go watch a prison break
the third season and reverse it for new
reasons and leave you Tegan you need to
practice some new breathing meditation
or place a mental game like six degrees
of Kevin Bacon really hard and leave
held in heaven shaken and you'd be like
God why have you forsaken me we're still
in church from earlier and we're in very
ornate furniture yeah just like your
grandma's [ __ ] with the plastic we still
represent tender prophylactics
yeah not sponsorship we're getting money
from imaginary monsters [ __ ] again this
right here on the table and that's not a
fable it's not a fable it's not a story
it's not a Authority
this [ __ ] is boring kicking it I'll give
a [ __ ] [ __ ] some top some some licorice
götze Mediterranea a korean spot or
asian place or a soulful place and i
ordered a chicken dish everybody that
was epic yeah I was feeling this we
[ __ ] kill that centric fost my he
[ __ ] now Netflix yeah my my you snap a
man you snap I mean you know I camped up
a little bit I got a rap a little you
know that's the only thing I do I got to
do it if it's happening right yeah a rap
if the rap is happening natural for you
die you just stories about your son ASA
being just a super rapper now and
wrapping himself to sleep you said you
wrapped yourself to sleep at night now
how does that work okay so we put them
to bed you know good night I love you
kiss hug all of that the moment we
closed the door we just hear rap you
know he's just in there rap well I'm the
best because because because I'm the
best because because because I was
rapping and he just goes to sleep he's
battling himself well you know how this
started this particular mode of Ravin
starting he told us one day me and my
wife that uh he likes to when he's in
bed
he likes to practice saying curse words
to himself well because that's that's
when he could say that's one you could
say it and who wants to learn how he
wants to know how to use them so he
practices before but yeah you hear I'm
in his bedroom just know what I mean we
never heard that part but it's developed
into this rap thing now he doesn't curse
in the raps but he was in there rapping
until he falls asleep every night he's
gonna be a good rapper
yeah he's these are getting the reps
he's already good at dance are you
pretty good as he called you out in the
battle yeah he tries to battle me all
the time oh yes to shutout gobble his
little ass you roast him oh my god
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah don't try to
rap against me you my seed open that
book and learn to read again when you go
into the toilets do and don't all around
it when you get a little older you're
gonna get grounded that's that's a new
genre we just created they're much about
other kids even if you don't rap you
should batter your kids
you're right know what yeah you should
want to rap about your kids right now
listen to this you've got kids you
should write a rap it's a question in
his face yeah and then have your friends
over and have them laughing like no you
don't want to do that cuz if one of his
friends might get you you don't want you
don't want one in the kitchen either one
of them might they might have to saw
your friends oh my oh I don't want my
friends everyone's gonna point out him
why you got my head sensitive man so I
can only I can only battle him when it's
just me telling you you should need to
go pro him too rapid himself to sleep
and just save it for it to show him when
he's older I put up a YouTube video him
yesterday cuz he wrote his first rhyme
yesterday yeah he actually wrote raps on
paper I've been trying to get him to do
this for a year was it dope it wasn't
dope the one don't think he said was I
turned microphones to styrofoam okay the
rest of it was just some kind of [ __ ]
gibberish I mean but it was it was it
was all English words he just wasn't
making any kind of pointed by anything
but don't we did it he wrote it without
it beat if we did it over to Pete that
[ __ ] sounded great
sometimes it's just well I remember he
posted up the body builder that's it was
and he was acting he was in the pocket
I'm not going
he went saying no words then saying no
I feel like that's like most popular rap
music you know he's he's cut from that
cloth yeah duh you think that could be a
segment on your TV show of my kid right
now
not your kid we'll just parents battling
their kids script it may be or actual
battles you know what you just kind of
yeah you just kind of gave me idea
that's actually I could do that look you
don't have to edit this out nobody still
it [ __ ] you dad you can't tell me I make
the room
[ __ ] don't tell me when to sleep I do
what I do
what I need okay dad dad it's me my own
personality don't tell me what to do dad
get up I don't leave me alone
[Music]
that was great I was just don't toddler
God God tumble still Paco
I love me on Facebook Thomas my favorite
place on internet it's a some more some
more positive place right okay it's a
it's more gentle and accepting and
inclusive yeah but it's also fun it has
some circles well it's I want to say sir
I mean cuz I think I know what you're
talking about you're talking about like
trolls and people just being dicks [ __ ]
like that like they don't do that but
since it's so inclusive and so accepting
everybody's like fetishes is welcome and
[ __ ] and it can get weird really get
real weird on tumblr every few months
I'll check
my messages on I'm really gone their
life of my site by website used to be
based on tumblr years back but I still
had so and then I looked through and
just have a bunch and just weird as
messages do you do you get messages to
yo-yo you have like a page on Facebook
like Hannibal Burres page it's not a
regular page that but I mean like a
hardest like on yeah what kind of you
must get the craziest I don't get
messages only I don't have that open
okay good cuz I get that's that's the
worst place on earth far as I'm
concerned is my artist page messages on
Facebook that's the worst on Facebook
yeah worst place on earth just people
just up whatever drivel artist page
messages yeah
this is [ __ ] hall because Facebook is
when people are really killing time to
look they at work they killing you know
they hate it there may be dis muhfucka
says he kind of just zone out on
Facebook I feel like people just get up
at 2:00 in the morning you know well you
know what is to Facebook is legitimately
everybody ya know and that's the problem
other social medias are most people but
it's not it's more snapchat for the most
part is younger people and like dj
khaled every cross and some basketball
players instagram is like everybody's
instagram there's a lot of you know
comedians models [ __ ] regular P but
Twitter is you know people want to but
everybody from maybe not younger people
as much but yeah cuz cuz once the
grandmas and the uncles and aunties and
[ __ ] got on facebook that's when all the
young people went to tumblr and snapchat
yeah they couldn't be there what they
couldn't be on the internet with Grandma
and [ __ ] so they had to like make up a
fake name to go on tumblr and learn
about you know sex from strangers and
[ __ ] like but isnt tumblr basically like
blogspot right
and Wool it kind of taking it for a
block hitbox got some blur
I do I tried it out for like a month and
I was like I don't get it now you see
cuz tumblr is really all about the
backend you know and I mean like if you
just look at the blogs and you don't
have one or you know really [ __ ] with it
you just see people's pages you know
just really good about the back end
because the back end is social just like
Twitter or Instagram or anything else
part like it's you know it's all about
reblogging [ __ ] but you don't if you're
only looking at it from the pages you
don't see all that [ __ ] it's a whole
other way that people engage on their
this you can't really see unless you're
like in it doing it and [ __ ] yeah but
what about Pinterest do you do Pinterest
you know I have a Pinterest yeah but I
feel like I don't know like the
Pinterest is is a it's mostly women's
that I've that I've that's my
understanding of it and it's just about
like I don't know like you just put
pictures of [ __ ] you like or I don't
know like I don't really haven't done it
Babylon has some insight on Pintrest
take it as half seriously no I find
Pinterest is where I go to find unique
art and stuff that people post you can
find like if you want to say like green
Ferraris green Porsche 911s or like all
the posters and [ __ ] to get graphic
design ideas yeah I got a pencil for
that oh [ __ ] I do that [ __ ] on tumblr
and deviantART you ever been a
deviantART deviantART is a great but no
FCS 42s he's for selling [ __ ] that you
make Oh gonna say one more thing gonna
be out I went to college with Emmanuel
Lewis because he was talked about him
earlier at Clark yeah it was me and one
class it was me Emmanuel Lewis K
embarrassed and by and Brian Bowers to
do who may hide a while all in one class
blackish
his credits some of it is in my house
[Laughter]
Pinterest yeah Ted told but totally
start off those pictures what about
Pinterest your pictures pictures but not
pictures on Pinterest like holy [ __ ]
he's allergic tangos from Bali
[Laughter]
CJ Sullivan ladies and gentlemen pot
roast what about stop me from my voice
yo you do you know why got a snapchat is
because this stripper that lived in
Boulder Colorado she like you got
snapchat you know like how they not get
snapchat I'll send you stuff and she was
my only friend on snapchat for a while
started mhm
sitting me titties and stuff and then
she started she stopped and now they're
just boring [ __ ] I thought what happened
for me it's exactly how it happened for
me to the rule sort of scratch off ah
let's see
uncover I
wait you weren't you well you weren't
knees I think wait no no no I think you
scratch them and it is that okay yeah
Wow
I think you just scratch all of cash
[Music]
cash cash
that's where you see that it doesn't say
that anywhere bottom actually win that
prize right but that's what that's the
bonus you should imagine something like
this would be a site that's plans cash
there's no game to it Cattleya taxable
does that I cannot take it you should
have that simple
[Music]
oh wow Tony trim and everyone you guys a
wreck this game almost this other
picture doing that drum be was ill
[Music]
[Music]
by CJ CJ Sullivan everybody that's a
closet
what about pencils you don't like
Pinterest
[Music]
this episode loses fun yeah this is uh
this is a wild one it'll be fun yeah I
like it though it's good cameos Poppins
yelling [ __ ] scratch-off ticket hey
Mikey [ __ ] Oh Mike scratch-off ticket
advice
random freestyles I was getting some
bars in tonight I usually never [ __ ]
spent the enema them dumb angsty
teenager bars man I had I had yeah I had
some things to say I got something say
yeah dad what you gotta say yeah no more
res well cat tell me where to do can't
tell me where to go so dad again go to
sleep what I want what the [ __ ]
dad what can I use the car no dad I [ __ ]
you I'm gonna use the car
[ __ ] them I'm gonna do I sleep cuz you
sleep [ __ ] apparently is your dad what I
said [ __ ] you dad I brought you in this
world oh yeah you guys are writing the
next Hamilton right here I love whine
whine whine whine whine whine as your
tour done you got a few more days nope I
head back out Tuesday man Tuesday to
where Atlanta Atlanta yeah Atlanta and
in Raleigh and in Cincinnati
cuz it's stupid this this part of the
tour is stupid it routing wise and land
of Raleigh Cincinnati you got open
nursery just yeah this leg I'm rolling
with Billy woods the first leg I roll
with Samus and the second leg I rolled
with
Milo under his scallops Hotel persona
scallops Hotel personas that he has a he
makes mostly instrumental projects under
this name scallops hotel Oh gotcha
and so yeah well he did this he did
scallops Hotel sets for his leg so he
had an Atlanta when you said Tuesday
Tuesday how'd they accept you in Atlanta
uh like here really cool shows there
yeah yeah
you know it's the situation where
through you know back when I was booking
myself I found the guy who actually
booked [ __ ] like me yeah and so we've
kind of developed a little thing down
they got you so it's been cool yeah it's
like this guy does not sound like future
well I mean you know his nd
[ __ ] everywhere though yeah I
was true you know these days and anyhow
everyone's got the little Hindi singing
his [ __ ] so it ain't been it ain't
banana ours a bunch of weird black
people in Atlanta so Atlanta dog when I
was down there when they premiered
flylo's movie coup so they premiered at
an Atlanta they've dubbed what a
premiere of it in Atlanta like the first
because they only limit it show it in
theaters and it was sold out and it was
just a bunch of it was a mixed crowd
he's a lot of black folk you know Jesus
yes black [ __ ] agilent's it whoa how did
they like the movie movie went over well
okay word it was but that [ __ ] is gross
I was I was wondering how the black
girls took the grossest I think they
knew what they were getting into both
cuz I don't know how anybody could know
what they was getting into with that
level of gross mister it's super yes
it's a lot even when when he asked me to
do it and he sent me what he was already
working on what this is whatever man
that's the lines I said I'll do it but
this [ __ ] is weird man well he was like
a roach or someone you would use like
some type of but some know sometimes
typecast as an insect it looked like
insect not being a row now ya know
wasn't a roast it wasn't a row to some
weirdo and he was weighing he was
riffing
somebody who is your if away I think
they had me riffing with Darnell okay
yeah but we didn't y'all went in the
room naw man this [ __ ] sound like y'all
was yeah I guess the way he cut it cuz I
that's tight yeah I just did it on I
think I was on FaceTime with Lotus and
he was just and then we just recorded it
I go that [ __ ] was crazy two other night
it was very crazy [ __ ] innocent so
you're miss immature no no I didn't
perform I haven't performed a cemetery
before you know that all that funeral
material man I do that anyway I do it in
all of my shows but it was oh this is
perfect I didn't think about it itself
earlier that day oh [ __ ] you got a bunch
of funeral material how many dead people
there yeah what what is it how is it for
you performing and a big music venue I
know you do a lot of [ __ ] like that
anyway but like how is it cuz your voice
echoing all over the place write it like
you know I mean how does it has it fit
as a field okay it varies okay
cuz that crowd the Flying Lotus
Thundercat crowd is familiar with me why
not I mean we've worked we all worked
together before Lotus was all why you
know what I mean I've been on other [ __ ]
with the FlyLo FM he been on a pack so
it's kind of uh it's a community much I
think for the most part a flat somebody
going to see Flying Lotus is aware me
right but some of the shells can be
tougher show with uh the the knives and
Lauren Hill shows with tougher because
it was the only thing I knew about them
yeah it was because how many shows Joe
do I did three things happen it sound
like things happen but uh yeah it would
be was funny cuz we would do you know
I'm only doing a 2025 minute set but I
would still do my same production so
that they were reggae band crow mix
chronics a chronics chronics
excuse they would go and then I was
going after the but then we do a
blackout the lights before I go out and
so the crowd will go crazy because I
think they think it nice but you put
your on the bill
yeah what a bit okay so it's okay so but
yeah it would just be it would be funny
to hear the cheer that's never me it is
empathy and and and so what was
challenging about it and in in that
circumstance versus the other day it's
different vibes where people are not in
that mo now you're not I mean in that
mode at all like some people are there
for me but it's the motors this is a
different approach it was one of the
gigs I was able to really crack them the
other ones were cool but in the one
outside DC because I just did you with a
big crowd there with all of them don't
know you you got to kind of do some just
some [ __ ] to get everybody so it was
like where the [ __ ] are we where is this
place
how the [ __ ] how long did it take to get
up oh just general ass [ __ ] anything
like yeah we did yeah she's like this in
DC why does every obvious glass just
regular [ __ ] just before and just simple
as far as up top with that type of crowd
you have to get them on some general
[ __ ] right away versus you know a comedy
crowd or a smaller thing you can just
kind of pop your knee back hey I'm weird
and just get into this you know yeah it
seems you know every time I see you do
it it come easy I just wonder like and
yo approach isn't any different you know
what I mean if you're going up to just
do a comedy show versus if you like cuz
then other night like you wouldn't on a
bill as far as I could tell now it was
late added on like they I know I've been
on it but then they put they didn't
announce it so late so probably most
people that bought their tickets early
probably but no it was I mean a lot of
time that people weren't
right out there either during the doing
my people he was a respectful I mean
beyond like a couple people yelling out
some [ __ ] as far as the audience they
was talking amongst themselves this is
all you really need dissent there and so
and that's not the case with yet not
everybody people kind of moving about
it's a outdoor everything people are
going up you know get drinks and [ __ ] so
it's kind of a busy room and it's a bit
distracting to you to me my bet is
different to because that show the other
night it was nighttime right like I
imagine if you're doing some [ __ ] like
that and his bright then people are
paying less attention maybe uh it was it
was night for a couple of them that was
it's just moving around and they night
it's only a small you know you talk
about out of eight ten thousand at a
nice long might be a couple honey that
came for me right so and then you got to
work for that it was fun yeah it was
that was a it was a strange experience
for me cuz the first couple nights they
didn't have the setup on the stage so I
had to work in the control room
but just roll they they have like a
separate control room that's like off in
like the back so I was like weird cuz I
was watching Hannibal so you can't even
like you alright you can yeah I couldn't
he couldn't communicate with me like he
couldn't see me it was like this weird
just I had to be on cue
anyway just had to trust me [ __ ] he
pulled it off it was cool but it's
always weird when I'm not on the stage I
was peeping at the other night - hell
yeah I didn't know where you were
exactly but you knew I was there
somewhere yeah because he got [ __ ]
coming on time and I know you know yeah
see nobody else there I got no security
guard pressing plays well some people do
that man
I've seen some comedians do a club and
they got sound cues and they just have
anybody doing name I guess they talked
it through it like it was soon when I
hit this [ __ ] press play time Wow you
trust a stranger that much live timing
cuz
do not at all know who's you who's that
you I was a SAP rock when I you did
tylerhall
yeah it's up here you uh you thought out
you you ended early what I popped out I
popped out to do duck Stanford Widow
yeah you know and he did you call me yes
this is this is what happened so I do
the song do the first verse I do the
hood and I go to call Hannibal
Hannibal's not ready so we end up making
kind of a thing out of that right
because like we kind of stopped a song
and was like yeah what happened and I
made a whole bit out of it and it was
funny as [ __ ] so then we started to song
over and I realized like halfway through
me redoing it that I have [ __ ] up I
didn't I didn't do my second first at
all so I called him out earlier then so
you can call me up and I started [ __ ]
up my verse cuz this I wasn't right that
it wouldn't make what even the right
point I wasn't in rhythm what the [ __ ] I
usually don't I'm a little buzzed but
I'm usually I was [ __ ] it out and
then I was like let's start it over and
then I almost want to say I did it again
[ __ ] up or something something happen
but I [ __ ] it up you know so the
second time around you didn't get it
right yeah I feel like it was a almost a
third time type situation it looked like
we were doing like a bit making fun of
guest verses and that's that was the fun
part of it like for the crowd there they
couldn't tell if we was really [ __ ]
it was worked out it did it worked out
it was super smooth just whatever song
year we got it
you gotta do another try gotta do
another trap yeah used auto-tune any
songs on my last album when I just put
out on the third verse of a song
there's auto-tune on but it's like a
light one in there like yeah but uh this
little box here you kind of changed in
my life over here right now just seen
you do that cuz I didn't really know you
could do that live like that yeah like
cuz grambler I thought you had to like
have keys programmed in knowing it Oh
some [ __ ] like you just got like octaves
of [ __ ] like see that [ __ ] that [ __ ] is
sexy G like I want to do that on stage
it's like it's magical it's the handsome
scrambler we don't we don't promote
right but I need to know Mike yeah I
think I need to get a get down in the
kickdown gang so I can hang in do my
thing and I can be on key when I start
to sang yeah I got to do it because it's
heaven when you got the right [ __ ]
melody yeah the ganache it is the
destiny cannot on hold key like a singer
in the 17th chapter raps though
seventies cast a war afro it's just like
Sly Stone rap now touch you in a
different time zone I'm home and my
phone is ringing but maybe that's just
texts and I'm rapping is just affects it
not bus I'll be like who's up next so I
stretch stretch stress stress stress
stress stress stress stress stress
Tiny's on the drums to hear where he's
coming from
kick it till his down thinking it's mine
we can start when it becomes back
where's the rhythm I'm a thumbtack
enough we'll give them something sharpen
up like them just like the string sass
on the heart I'd rather go play some
perfect dark and I can spark the world
I'm doomed and I can walk it more
blood-borne I'm just shielding just like
it was Folsom still a bowl so I bounced
on track like the stick that's called
the Pogo oh no oh no you can just call
me you know if you're Popeye one punch
will [ __ ] you know what do you know I'll
play you like games or uno emcees wanna
grab the mic but they do them slow I can
move fast with the rhythmic [ __ ] that
pinches push you in suspension you never
stop to get an honourable mention I
dispense with anyone who small enough
they can't take the ride in my [ __ ]
funny like The Princess Bride I'm just
old school my hair turns gold like gold
coal boom Joosten beaucoup and so you
will see if can do what oh dude I will
program rig hold your I am have a body
full of soju no this is whiskey I'm
chief kanisky emcees get the Blitzkrieg
like there was German wash the ass with
detergent and emergency room if they are
see-through icy plumes of smoke I'm
super dope I play Nintendo with the
super sculpey
6 [ __ ] their brick some 1886 8686 you
can miss me with that haiti [ __ ] what
earthquake I make my shirt shake cuz I'm
doing the Harlem shake
and I'm drinking a shake while I'm in
Harlem doing the Harlem shake
eat the shake and bake with cake ate the
cake Ida may be well you know go to jail
take $200 and go to the commissary I
look like I roll in the 90s 99 is where
you try to find his Lord 1 9 9 9
everything is going fine I'm drinking
gin and why
mix up that [ __ ] don't taste good I must
split up drink them separately our lady
hearts of gold
Shepard's gee what the [ __ ] my left old
got left for see I don't got leprosy but
it might as well the way and let I go
get pedicures I got a 200% tip it's just
as hot a look totally true thank you
yeah he trembles made me feel like I'm
on drugs Tony I love this new setup that
mo mo just hit us up be fingering
everything over there Tony
there's all the drums sound like without
the pedals is it this one is the one
this one
what is that what is my song yeah it's
the yeah this one I was trying to
remember if it was the second track got
a yeah is this the one with the hook
that sound like a verse the way I don't
and I should also get back on the
microphone so that I can be heard while
you're asking me questions I don't call
it is because I feel like they begin my
fit out of hair like the Dome of the
stag become you think it sound good but
it's really you cracked agenda back at
now ladies in the clinic innate if you
don't turn away from me look at my I
hope my brother got heart but he running
with cybele's
it's gonna be a while
oh yeah I hold it like infinity gems
policeman looking at me like I'm finna
be here now daddy gets a hard man my
mother's a ghost I keep my head covered
them my brother will boast to Goffe
[ __ ] with my hair without stuff and
each else a rare huh my footprints
covered the coast and I'll be running
through walls cuz I'm [ __ ] but in most
the night Walter tried to creep the
smell suckers approach he's sick him all
charged to give what he provoked the
homie time got balisong tugging his
cloak yeah I'm being as hell can't fit
in my fit my sleeves ripped on the king
so my ring is legit a bring [ __ ] to your
front door ready to bail my eyes glow in
my hood like a demon from Hell my spells
in my hand it's up to me to pepper
yeah right that's Frieza the free hook
okay free hook I like that yeah I
believe I'll be writing songs with like
five parts to [ __ ] there's so many vocal
parts like that track that's because it
because I was is this a does he still
rapid I just go it goes in smoothly I
guess the real working in song is ain't
nothing gonna stop me no yeah that's
gonna but then your black tie guy style
ever composed I gotta put all that [ __ ]
like it's all hooking it's very hook
yeah I'll be writing songs with five
foot size shouldn't even say it's a
bunch of parts I write a bunch of hooks
person like Chief Keef is that what he
does he does he does summer I've seen
the I've seen the live show yeah and
that's the that's it
yeah those are the songs like it's just
choruses
deceptively hard to do it's probably cuz
if if it wasn't something to it yeah
yeah bar to be doing it see now you
think you just did it though I think
you're just didn't like I think that's a
hook right there
then once on tour everybody be doing it
if it was some toward a party big body
big doing if the one son to a party big
doing it everybody big to never once up
to add bad faith food if the button up
to my to be doin a fine you want the one
that if is the easy street if they they
some to a larger do because you can't do
it so we can't do this per week I'm
doing it cuz you can't do it you can do
it if you could do you will [ __ ]
going the [ __ ] is like so much
you can't really do it i'ma do it that
you can't do it go to the story yo you
got the same access to the same machines
but you can't do it just like me
everybody do it if they could but they
can't so they can't do it so they just
hate you can't just write - they can't
do it cuz they're not as cold as weight
is they can't do it something in the
[ __ ] wrong [ __ ] they try to make a
[ __ ] complicated song is not the
thing that you you just make you insane
change your voice to chill wrap from
wait see see it's just trying to grab it
and squeeze me they can't do it I'm a
different [ __ ] speech sings yeah I
just make the science I break your
[ __ ] down like oh that's applying
listen try it again I play them like a
violin emcees not strong enough they
take they bite me yeah yeah yeah I feel
I'm getting complex I should make you
simple look again again again again yeah
yeah make fast smoke the ass smoke some
grass smoke smoke
[Music]
[Music]
yeah yeah
you can't gangbang when it's only one
game cuz then every [ __ ] gang is the
same thing and that mean we out gang on
the same say we can't gangbang we all on
the same I say just the same smart way
of criticism we wear blue you wanna wear
red [ __ ] I dare you
and ecology smothers is secretly just a
bunch of Crips they just get together
and they start to [ __ ] flip oh yeah
they just say what the hell dates and
cribs and the only [ __ ] blood is as
we yell oh yeah as Riel or maybe
Gargamel they'll be you browned that
[ __ ] and they'd be like what's that
smell
mr. smashing what the hell what the hell
what the hell I'm a smurf I'm in jail
[Music]
[Music]
only one female everybody wanted now she
charged and retail this [ __ ] is [ __ ]
up this is our economy I served the went
to college maybe she will [ __ ] with me
but she won't cuz it just [ __ ] one
higher and I'll be waiting for but
another [ __ ] girl to occur it doesn't
happen all the smarts and [ __ ] dudes
I don't understand it man it's just not
[ __ ] cold not cool the suitors will
warm infest my goddess Ertel much a
sublet my chest itself while I'm in the
saddle up I would just the film
if I need to wake up a wig or a protest
here sound is my old alarm clock I'll
rip my chest hands out to make myself up
if I gotta get up to suit a movie and
six and I'm that really woke him hyung
go out rip my chest hairs up in that
waist me right the [ __ ] up and I go in
same word so camera that's a rip of my
home's as a have I say a wardrobe give
me a wife beater she say why yes sir
that you wear it on camera is blue I say
I know but I got blood on my chest and I
don't want that blood to bleed through
and ruin the shot so just give me your
white beaver in the eggs l so I can't
cover up all my scabs and sales from
there much chest hair out it's my own
alarm clock master alarm clock Tony
Roberts taught me about that [ __ ]
he's saved it's just hair all right you
get all pumped up as [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
yeah every one of you hurt ourselves
every morning and hurt yourself every
morning you hurts ourselves every
morning you hurt yourself do what you
got to do to wake up from your deep
asleep you got to do you got to do so
you can wake up from your deep asleep
yeah yeah even if you got to bleed yeah
do whatever you need yeah yeah
do what you need yeah yeah make yourself
plea yeah pull that chest hair out so
you know what the mornings about you got
to do that
that show was long class it doesn't
matter if that [ __ ] it's not hot
that's what you got to do to get ya
gotta get up gotta give yourself pain
Jim give yourself pain that's what you
need for your own damn brain yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'll rip my church that's how I do it
and I know I'm the best [ __ ] yourself I
don't need no zip I just need to rip the
hair out of my chest and that's just
what I do is I'm the best
every morning I manifest I whip my hair
out from my chest and not look in the
mirror and say today's blessed yeah and
now I'm bleeding
now I got just what I needed its
nutrients because I misleading I'm a
seedling now I'm bleeding my self
flagellation that's how I do when I'm on
a date I'd be in the bathroom and I say
that I had to pee but I'm just making
myself clean that's what I need so I can
wake up and be at the right speed other
than that I'm just too slow all you pay
for [ __ ] know
[Music]
[Music]
I think we got a nderstand I don't know
if does that yeah I don't think we'd go
yeah thank you
yeah that's it baby hey hey brick buddy
kiss yeah yeah it all sounds like what
you just heard
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]